for we have a quorum
calling in the order and
secretary please call the
roll quirk here work is here
Melendez this is here I don't
have your number here okay have
Holden all this year
Mathis here you have
to cheat Obernolte
we have warranted six and sorry
-- Mr Maienschein you can make
a short presentation thank
you very much Mister chair
AB one AB one reconciles a
conflict with the federal state
cooperate verifying the have
respectfully from participating
and fees for permit
applications the California
department move my bill
-- nearly to say lawful
and here with me on
the question yeah
in this case maybe
all right anyone else for a
single anyone in opposition
questions
-- I think it's a great deal
takes care of a conflict
between federal law and
state law and -- I hope
we get unanimous vote
madam secretary please call the
roll this is AB one eight one
man chime with recommendations
that Senate amendments be
concurrent quirk on quirk I
will end this time what is hi I
don't know and I will by our K.
hand I yeah Cristina Garcia
Holden Holden aye Mathis aye
Mathis aye what a to G.
Obernolte five
I
to members it's out
I'll wait a couple of ways
yeah couple of minutes from
for around two G.
yeah key and -- assembly
member Muratsuchi and assembly
member Cristina Garcia
yeah okay thank you
okay
yeah
this is to our S.
as a bigger problem
the national resource
center travel
three
hi Christine
hi passed the bill great
if you want to add yeah the
vote is at seven zero yeah
because you know it's not high
that's okay a way to come
go ahead eight zero or voting
on Maienschein I is that okay
and what I did you would have
to Jackson at that unanimous
vote nine zero one AB one AB
one yeah the easy one okay two
door thanks everyone yeah --
gap yeah thank you all right